Alright everyone, we are having a very good afternoon and
welcome to Infinity Learn Neat by Shri Chaitanya.
Children, you are very welcome to our beautiful platform with this very
information in which
we are going to tell you in detail
what is the syllabus in Biology, Physics, Chemistry.  Has it been deleted
? Has your syllabus been added? As you
all children know that the latest update of NMC
came yesterday and based on that, a
circular was being rotated. Based on that, we have already
taken your class and told you.  That
is the authentic NMC circular which has been
rotated, so
now how should you read according to that circular, let
me explain to you from the perspective of biology.
From the perspective of complete chemistry, CM
Sir is going to come and explain to you, so
what are the things like this in biology?  There are
some things which have been added, there are also some things which have been deleted,
so you are going to get peace of mind and there are
some things which you will have to read out of
NCRT,
where will you read them, I am telling you today in this article.  I am going to
tell you in the session, so children, first
thing first, you will mark your attendance immediately. Like the
session in the class,
share it and invite all your friends. You do
not have to invest too much time at all.
We will prepare you and complete the lesson in maximum 203 minutes.  We will
tell you about Biology Physics Chemistry whether there has been an
update in the syllabus so that now the
students of 2024 can direct their studies in this
manner. See more and
less. Now only seven months are left for you, so
now is the time.  How will we be able to use
our same syllabus,
what level of paper can we expect,
we will discuss all these things
in today's class. Okay, so let's get started without any further
delay. Let's
start right away.  Let's
start with Botany. Children, if
I tell you about Botany, then what all
our syllabus has been deleted,
we will talk about it first. We will also talk about what has been added.
We will also talk about many children in
my  I was getting a message
from the last two-three days that ma'am, this part has been added to the syllabus in
Botany, that is your Morpho ji,
this part is Malvaceae family, your
Cruciferous family, your composite,
from where will we study these families because these
Families have not been given to us even in NCRT. On
one hand, NMC says that the
paper of your NEET will be NCRT
centric paper and on the other hand, in the syllabus that has been
released, some topics have been
given which are not mentioned in NCRT.  If so,
where to do this topic, who will get it
done, how to do it, what type of
questions will come on this, we are going to
talk about all these things today, yes of
course Kumar, if I want to explain all the things to you,
then first of all I will start with
What has been added, the thing that has been added in Botany that
is out of NCRT, if you
look at your Morph chapters,
you will not see these topics in that chapter.
A specifically C. Morpho Ji
till now we had families, Brassy.
Only and only diagram of Casey was given,
apart from that, Solanaceae was explained in detail,
Fabaceae and Lilies were explained in detail,
so we used to study these three families in detail:
Fab AC, Solanaceae and Lily AC, Basic
AC.  Question was also raised on Reason Being
Starting, where semi technical
formula is given, the
complete floral formula has been given to you in the form of a diagram.
We used to think that it
is given in NCERT, so here  This question
can definitely be yours but now this year,
some
extra families have been added to the topic, we have
Malvaceae family, we have Cruciferous family, we have Legume
family, we have
Compositae and Gramineae, these five.  Now we will have to
study in detail, if you
want selection in 2024, then my personal advice is that
you children should
study very well in detail whatever has been added,
whether it is in mathematics or zoology, only after thinking about
these topics.
Okay, let's do the second thing. If
your syllabus has been deleted, then some of the
chapters have been deleted. There are
some chapters in which some
topics have been added on or deleted.
Okay.  So first let me explain
which chapters have been removed. If I talk about the
chapters in Botany, then
in Plant Physiology you have five
chapters: Transport in
Plants, Number Two, Mineral Nutrition, Number
Three, Photosynthesis, Than We Have Respiration.
We Have Plant Growth and Development Out of these
five chapters, your Transport
in Plants has been eliminated, Mineral
Nutrition has been eliminated,
Photosynthesis as it is, Respiration as it
is,
Some topics have been removed within Plant Growth and Development.  Like
seed dormancy has been deleted,
photoperiodic has been deleted
and in fact photoperiodic question used to be made, yes vernalization has been
removed,
a question used to be made from here too, so
in Plant Growth and Development.  These
three topics of yours have been removed. If we
go to 12th then the first chapter on Reproduction in Organisms has been deleted. The
entire chapter has been
deleted. I am saying that ma'am, it is a
good thing, if you did not even remember about mental nutrition,
then it is good.  There
are some things which have been deleted which will give you
some relief after seeing the deleted ones. There are some things
which may shock you after seeing them,
like Reproduction in Organism, there
was something extra in it, one or two
questions are coming from here.
You people used to read some portions of it in Sexual Reproduction,
some portions of it you people used to
read in Morpho G, some portions of it
you people used to read in Angiosperms part,
so there was no need to read anything extra in it,
but its weightage added.  If it was possible then
you would have got one or two extra questions,
but now this entire chapter has been
removed, in fact Strategy
for Enhancement of Food Production, the entire
chapter has also been removed from the
Botany part. Okay, let's move ahead.
Living World, which is your first chapter, which is
your last topic within Living World,
Tools for Study of Taxo, which
is your Taxol Aids,
this entire topic has been removed from this topic,
your Museum, Zoological Park,
Herbarium, Botanical Garden.  What we used to read were
keys, what we used to read, what is flora, what is manual,
what is catalogue, this entire part has been
deleted, so this one topic of the living world has been
completely
deleted from here, then comes plant
kingdom.  If we talk about this chapter, then
algae have been explained to you within the plant kingdom,
bryophytes, perms and angiosperms.
Now you can see that every year two-three questions were being asked from algae only.
In the exam paper
also, you will see more questions about algae.
Used to be, the part related to angiospermic was
given in it. Basically, I would say that
you read the same portion in MorphoG,
you read the same portion in SRFP,
so there was nothing extra in it. If you
want, you can mention double fertilization.
We have male and female gametophytes in it,
you have already read it, it is okay, so it had
no relevance here, it is very
good that it got deleted from here, so there is nothing
different in it, you will read this thing, you will
definitely read about the contribution of angiosperms to
plants.  Life cycle which is
alteration of generation. Now see, even though
this topic has been disappeared from the last page,
but when you read the algae, you know
that the main dominant phase inside the algae is
your gametophytes on
top of it.  If it is sporophytic, then in this way you already
understand the life cycle, beet algae,
beet
bryophytes, plums, then separately the
topic given to us in the last section on life cycle has been
removed, but yes, if
you read this, then you already know this.  If you understand, then I did
not see any special relevance to it,
okay, after that, the classes of Angiosperm,
classification up to two classes,
about monocot and dicot, again you will
read in detail, okay within Morpho,
which is the characteristic features and
examples.
Specifically about Angiosperms, I would say that the
Angiosperms part of the Plant Kingdom has been
completely removed from there. It is okay
and in the syllabus that has been added,
only the Morpho-Gee part has been added. It
is okay, this is about your Botany.
Now let's move on to Zoology. Look, there
is no such separation left in Botany Zoology because in all the papers,
your Botany and Zoology come separately,
but you see, section A is also
filled with Botany questions,
pick up the 2023 paper,
Jaljeera.  Questions on Molecular Basis
were yours, aren't you, you will go with it's complete bio,
okay, Jaljeera, if I talk,
then we will mention some chapters which have been deleted in the syllabus,
then we
have Digestion and Absorption, the entire chapter is
yours to delete.  We have animal
husbands, this is also your chapter that has been deleted.
Environmental Issues. Now you can read this ecology
part in Batne whether you want to.
Jaljeera, Mental Issues, which was a chapter in the last chapter, has been
deleted. However,
my personal opinion is that it  There
should have been a chapter because
you people are the youth of the nation, you people are the future of India,
so how you have to preserve the environment is
a must read in
your studies but anyway this is not about
my opinion this is  What NMC has sent us?
Okay, so environmental issues have been
completely deleted. Then comes
neural control and coordination.
Within this, your reflex action. This topic has been
deleted. What has been added?
I will tell you about this in the next slide.
In the chapter Neural Control,
your sense organ has been deleted, then the
elementary structure of eye and ear has been
related to the right.
In Ecology, you have a chapter on Organism and
Population. From this chapter, you have the
part about Habitat and Niche.
Population and Ecological Adaptations has been removed.
Now again from Ecological Adaptation,
your question was being formed, so this was something
which was important but yes, now
if it has been removed this year, then you
do not need to read this topic.  Okay, Then
Comes Add, what has happened? If I
talk about add on in Zoology, children, then
your add on is Human Health and Disease, I
would say that it is a very good add on
that Parasite Causing Human Disease Dengue
and Chicken Gunia.  You will have to read the full details of it.
If I talk about not only
NCR here, apart from this I
also talk about outside, then
you get a lot of cases of dengue and chicken gonorrhea
and you must have also felt that
In recent years, the number of
deaths is also increasing very much, so this is a way to educate people about this
disease, how
can you prevent it, then this is a good
move. Dengue and chicken gonorrhea have been added to both
and also tobacco abuse.  If it has been added,
then these topics have been added to yours.
What has been deleted? I told you that
two-three topics have been deleted from the organic and population part.
Environmental issues have been completely removed.
Your reflex action sense organ under neural control.
Elementary Structure of
Eye and Ear has been removed and Digestion
and Absorption has been completely removed. Animal
Husbandry has been completely removed, so this is your
Botany and Jaljeera added on and deleted.
Okay, we will also tell you about Chemistry and Physics.
What things have been added in your details?
What things have been deleted? For
Chemistry and Physics, I would like to invite
Mrityunjay Sir to explain to you
in detail. Sir, what has been added to your chemistry and
what has been deleted? Please
tell the children, Hello.  Everyone, how are you all? So
ma'am, I can quickly tell this to the
children for chemistry because it is
written here in a very detailed manner
that what has been added and what has been subtracted,
so children, you all are happy.
After seeing Geology, once we
discuss Chemistry, then the chapter which you have removed from class 11th
is State of Matter,
Hydrogen, its Compound, S Block. Okay, so
these three chapters are removed from our Physical and
Energic Chemistry.
OK, first let's look at the deleted ones,
then Environmental Chemistry, OK, then
smile, hello, how are you? Surface Chemistry,
Solid State Metal, Energy, Polymer and
Chemistry in Everyday Life, so neither our
chapter has been removed from Class 11th Class 11,
nor have our chapters been removed. OK, so I hope, OK, so more.
But what has been added, actually we used to
study this topic earlier in the name of salt analysis, it was taught less in general medical,
but for JE, we used to teach this in advance,
but now that syllabus has been officially added
for your medical also.  Okay
children, Muskaan Kumar, I hope you are understanding these things,
so what has been added is the
syllabus, this is a little bit about us in the earlier times,
how many children are there who have
already studied a little bit of salt analysis, so it is as if there is some analysis in
it.
For identification of those properties, you can see
detection of extra elements,
nitrogen, sulfur, halogen, especially in this
chemistry, organic chemistry,
already in your syllabus there was
practical chemistry which was of organic,
okay, then here detection of following functional
group, hydroxyl.  Alcoholic Phenolic,
we have been studying these types of groups before also,
okay and secondly, the chemistry evolved in
the preparation of aortic compounds like
Mohr salt and potash salt, so actually we have been studying
some things of double salt, now we have
studied a little bit sir.
Ok Kumar for one shot, yes absolutely one salt
analysis, actually there is no trend in teaching medicine in medical, it was
general for JE advance but as you can see
which is the next topic like here you
will come here so what is yours organic
compounds  Like your nitro nitro
etla id analyne aloe iodo form ok the
chemistry evolve in the tito metric
exercise acid base and the the usage of
indicators oxalic acid vs kmno4 so
you one thing this is the topic isn't it children it is
somewhere if you have many advanced  Version
slightly upgraded version: When chemistry
teachers used to teach you, they used to add all these things somewhere in ionic
equilibrium in moles or in redox.
Okay,
but now it is official, it has become a part of your syllabus.
Okay, next chemical principle
evolve in.  Qualitative Salt Analysis I
said, salt analysis has been done by you and
especially this analysis, okay, this analysis and this ancient principle evolved
in the formation
of a sorry following experiments,
Enthalpy of solution of copper sulphate,
you also
read this a little earlier in Thermodynamics.  Isn't it, other children,
how many such children or the
children who have been studying with me,
how many numericals have I already made them study on
Enthalpy of Neutralization of
Strong Acid and Strong Base? Can
you have you remembered?  Please take everyone
Kumar Muskaan, I have also made you do this topic before,
okay and this is your surface
chemistry, it is not more than that, no, Kumar, not
more has been added than has been deleted.
Actually, preparation of
Lyophilic and Lyophobic soul
in surface chemistry.  There was a small part in which the
chapter has been completely removed but they have kept this little bit which is the
reason behind it and this is the
topic which you are watching B and A are
watching, you have actually been
studying this in thermodynamics, so this is  Every
teacher has already been teaching the additional
problem which has been added, which will
take you some time, this in salt analysis,
qualitative test of Katay and Nayan,
okay, you will take some time
in qualitative salt analysis, this and a
little bit, this one.  It will not get better overnight,
you will have to pay a little
attention to which
reagent is which and all is ok and all the rest also
like see titres ok, especially
indicators oxalic acid vs kmno4,
all these are also already taught in detail by the chapter teacher.  When we were
living, not much
syllabus has been added. Yes,
it is a big deal for salt analysis to be officially added to you.
Okay, this is about chemistry, so
tell me. Deleted chapter nine. Chapter nine should be completely
deleted. This is a big deal, whoever
took the decision.  Yes, but only a nominal syllabus has been added, but it
looks big, but there
is nothing like that, okay children, okay,
so this is the part of chemistry, now let's come
and do the kinetic study of the reaction of
iodide ion with hydrogen peroxide at
Room temperature, so this is also somewhere,
if your redox etc. is good, if your
titre is good, then we read all this,
okay and it is easy,
don't worry about it, you just need to cut a little bit
in the qualitative test of ion ion.  A little
extra will suffice. Okay, now let's get into
Physics. How many people in Physics have asked more
questions from Organic?
Yes Kumar. Yes, you are going absolutely right.
A part from both Physical and Organic
is very important. No, from
Aortic.  Now there are less chapters left, so the
number of questions will be more, that is, the
weightage of that chapter has now increased, it is okay to remember,
so deleted chapter, if we talk about Physics, then
what is the use of you more than the chapter here, children, the topic has been
deleted.  Is there any more question? Will yes yes
Kumar, let's go to unit and measurement,
measurement of mass length and time, accuracy
and precision, these are some of your topics here,
okay chemical system of
particle and rotation, motional method of
determination of center mass by integration.
And in Gravitation, Geostationary and Polar
Satellites, how many people are happy with its removal.
In Chemistry, many people would be happy.
Everyday Life Environmental.
They used to have problem in reading. Okay,
I think all these parts were fine for the children. It might be
here.  There is a little problem in
this section and all this was
good for the children. Okay, and let's see it deleted once.
Then here the children, oh,
we have already said this. Okay, then do you know
what is dumb forced in oxygen?  Clam
Dam Oxalate and Resonance OK
What has been deleted in Mechanical Properties of Solids Elastic
Behavior of Material Bridges
Cranes and Mountains Strain Energy OK
and Puzzled Equations in Mechanical Properties of Fluids
So how do people feel after removing all this from Fluid
Mechanics?
How do you feel about this part? Let's
first look at the deleted topics
in Physics and Thermodynamics. Heat Engine
Refrigerator Brief Information Neat but
Derivations are not required. First of all, this is an
easy portion. The child enjoys.
Requirement of Derivations.  So no, okay,
now let's see what all has been added. So
children, people have also added, please tell me from your heart, whatever
topics have been added here, they have
specially mentioned them.
If you are doing a detailed analysis of Physics, then anywhere else.  If you
are there then all these topics would have been
taught to you already like
experimental skills actually added
here and almost whatever has been added one and
two weeks a and Yash Kumar even that heat engine and
refrigerator are so easy that many times
we get excited about chemistry.  I used to teach only in
chemistry and in chemistry itself some formula based
questions used to come like Are you agree and not
Muskaan and Kumar Vishal ok so child people,
this has added familiarity with the basic
approach and observation of experiments
and activities. First Vernier Caliper. How many
people?  Who was already teaching in their physics teacher's
class because I used to teach my
friends who are our teachers
very hard and used to take Vernier Caliper and
teach it in the class, so
earlier too I was studying at a good place.
Okay, now I have specially mentioned this.
Many people who used to skip this will now
not be able to skip this. Okay, because I have been
taught it myself. Okay, so
Vernier Caliper is used to measure internal and
external diameter and depth of a vessel. Okay, it's
this.  So from last yes yes Kumar no
earlier people used to teach there was no mention now what is there now it has become mention
ok screw gauge it is
used to determine thickness diameter of thin
seat and wire simple pendulum ok dissipation of
energy by plotting a graph between the
square of  Amplitude and Time are
actually the experimental
phenomena which have now been made mandatory for you.
Complexity will ask, actually many people
used to teach this earlier too. Okay yes Kumar yes
okay meter scale the mass of a given
object by the principle of moments.
Ok, Young Modulus of Elasticity of
Material of Metallic, this is an easy topic is
n't it, we have read this earlier also, Surface Tension of Water
by Capillary Rise and Effect of
Detergents, OK, Oil Slick, OK, Effect of
Detergent, OK, so children, how did you like all these topics?
What has been added to you
in Physics now but Chemistry has become more or
not or chapters have gone and we will talk about that too
and what has been added here is coefficient of
viscosity of a given liquid
by measuring terminal velocity of a given liquid.
Spherical body ok and speed of sound in
air at room temperature using resonance
tube maja aayega ok a specific hit
capacity of given solid and liquid by
methods of mixture ok so these are the topic which is
dead in physics ok and children log to
kaisa laga best  In which one there has been more reduction?
Butni Geology, I have not
seen it. Good work has been done in Physics.
In Physics, I felt that a little balance has been done. Instead of focusing on the
top chapter, a little bit has been
played on the topic. Chemistry, so what does it mean?
What should I say? Okay in Organic.
Chemistry teacher will shift to teach no no
no, it is not like that, you see I am talking about chemistry,
I will take two more minutes, then I
also have a session on coordination, okay, look
child, what is there, now you are thinking like this, you have become
so distant here.  How far have we moved away from the energy channel,
one is fine, how many have moved away from here, chapters two and three have been
moved away from here, now think for yourself and
see, when the medical will balance organic
aortic and physical, then now
more questions will come from less chapters on aortic, i.e. about
chemical bonding.  The value has increased, now
what has come in the most weightage chapter, you are wrong in
thinking, you are thinking that there will be
more chapters of organic than organic, hence there will be
more questions, but still when the
paper will be balancing, okay when the
paper will be balancing, then children, you can Kumar
Muskaan.  You are able to believe this, now you will
see how many
good questions will come from these chapters of yours, now if you want to
ask more questions from less chapters, then the level will also
increase, that is why now you will have to do
well in the topics of inorganic. Okay, coordination
compound is the most important and tricky, so
chemical bonding is left.  Okay, your
coordination is left, two major areas are
left, D & F is left, P
block is left, so children, the questions will
still be dangerous, okay even, I think it is
wrong to remove this, in a way, your okay.
Children, please subscribe to this channel to get all the sessions that we take,
daily quiz, schedule, notes,
assignments and many mores and our
teaching notes,
and that
channel is Infinity Learn Under Learn Under NEET
OK.  Muskaan I hope this is a perfect
idea, this PDF will be
shared to you immediately on this Tegra channel. Okay
and children, complete P block on this channel
yes yaas supati hai syllabus is in 13
to 18 group so you can think yourself.  This is
important and children, okay now let's
meet in some time on this channel regarding
coordination chemistry, so today we
will discuss it a little heartily
and tomorrow we will discuss the same again at 11 o'clock,
okay so coordination
chemistry.  Let's try to understand today,
I will brief you,
read about the chapter and tomorrow we will raise questions on it,
see you in the next discussion, till then
bye.